in this video we're going to be talking
about three things that can increase
your views and ultimately increase your
increase your click-through rate on your
videos I'm going to be sharing some tips
for titles as well as some of the
lessons we've learned on thumbnails as
well and if you just want beginner and
basic stuff this video isn't for you but
ultimately if you want some real
tactical Advanced YouTube
tips then stick around until the end
because this is going to be a super
powerful video our premise today is just
changing the video tile title or
thumbnail effect views does changing
your video title or thumbnail affect
views after you upload a brand new video
and do you pivot after an hour a couple
hours to improve performance or even a
video that is weeks old months old or
even years old can you go back and
improve the performance of the video by
changing the title or the thumbnail
today's video is brought to you and
sponsored by vidiq.com forward slash
think but more on them later and let's
dive into part one of three parts the
power of changing the title of an
existing video let me tell you a quick
story and so a few weeks ago we uploaded
a video over on think media I recorded
this coffee with Channel show on our
think media podcast in the second half
of it we have a guest today and we do
some coaching we're also going to do
some q a but
ultimately we uploaded this video and
you can see uh that this is the title
how to make a thousand dollars a month
with affiliate marketing on YouTube you
can see YouTube says fewer viewers are
choosing to watch this video if you're a
regular viewers so performance is down
on the video you can see that the
impression click-through rate is also
3.8 percent and it's also gray it's not
over performing it's under performing
how it normally would perform and so
after this video was out for maybe four
hours and 17 minutes as you can see here
a pivot was made and you can see on
screen where that pivot was made
performance was altered for sure the Arc
of the blue line was going to
underperform it was going to undershoot
that gray range that gray range where
the view performance is is kind of like
the average performance on your channel
from a low or high
uh you know range in terms of of you how
many views the video gets based on your
last 10 as well as your total Channel
average across videos of course your
goal is to create a banger that
outperforms your typical video uh or to
at least just perform as well but this
video was under performing but when the
change was made you could see that for
sure it went from kind of a trajectory
like this to Boom it started to go up
and so what was that attributed to just
another screen to look at is the YouTube
studio app if you haven't downloaded on
your phone
the YouTube studio app it's different
than the main YouTube
app so you consume and watch YouTube on
your phone with the YouTube app make
sure you get that uploaded I mean update
it always updates your app uh but also
get the studio app and that continues to
improve you get more data and you can
see here again you can see that blue
line trajectory
um on screen here of kind of going flat
and then boom not only does it increase
but now we also see it cutting through
the gray typical performance see that by
the time you reach the right side of the
screen it is now uh reaching into
average and even above average if that
blue line continues so the thing to
notice here is that if we have a theory
like does changing the title or the
thumbnail improve performance we don't
want to base it off emotions we don't
want to base it off just like I feel
like it did it kind of seems like it did
but the fact the cool thing about
YouTube is It's All About Numbers it's
all about math and after doing this test
I was able to see that two percent uh
click-through rate was improved
um I don't think I wrote the notes down
here they didn't transfer maybe I have
it on this next screen or the previous
one but but ultimately I want to say
this went it dropped all the way down to
like a
two point
five and went up to a 4.3 or whatever so
it actually improved the click-through
rate by two percent
simply changing just the title and I
think I have Clarity on that I'll come
back to those exact numbers in just a
second so here's the process so what do
we do how did we go and I say we I used
to do this as an individual right but
now I'm talking of the think media team
and so in this case uh Steph got
involved he's on kind of focuses on our
think media podcast and then Nolan got
involved so we just had a couple people
we're talking in slack and it started
with me seeing the video underperforming
I think step number one is to know man I
think this video could do better when
you get to a place where you release a
YouTube video and you're like man what
what could be wrong with this is there
something wrong with the title is there
something wrong with the thumbnail what
could I maybe do to improve this and so
I got to work and I went to
uh
my thought was the title could be
improved and could be clearer so this
was my I started typing and I used this
website you can see it's called Monster
insights that actually gives you a
headline rating score to kind of
brainstorm a couple different titles
they all rated a 93 which is incredibly
High the 76 one wasn't very great but
you could see again the original video
was like how to make a thousand dollars
a month with affiliate marketing on
YouTube now from a headline score
standpoint that was a 93 it's kind of
tough to be throwing these tools at you
because somebody might go oh does 93
mean it's gonna work you got to have
like a deeper level of intuition than
that I think it takes a while to
cultivate that but it's like you use the
tool but you also have to like
understand humans like you use the tool
but you gotta like cultivate your
marketing knowledge and your psychology
psychology knowledge because if it was
all just about how much this website
scored it well they're all equal so how
would you decide so I'll kind of talk
through our process but there was how to
make a thousand dollars a month with
affiliate marketing how to make your
first a thousand dollars of affiliate
marketing on YouTube how to make your
first thousand dollars on YouTube in the
next 30 days removing affiliate
marketing how to earn a thousand dollars
on YouTube in the next 30 days without
AdSense how to reach a specific desire
in a specific amount of time without
you're not monetized yet or something
and that's searchable how to make a
thousand dollars a month on YouTube
without AdSense and how and then the
really short ones too how to make a
thousand dollars a month without AdSense
okay you see that so this was a slack
thread and I kind of started by when I I
do this often we release a new video I
see it
I feel it and I start brainstorming
title thumbnail concepting title
flip-flopping and so we started this
conversation in a ways down the
conversation stuff's like uh this one's
good too how to make your first a
thousand dollars on YouTube in the next
30 days now this was a pretty major
pivot
um but here's here's what one of the
most significant reasons why I believe
performance increase and all that was
changed was the title not the thumbnail
in this case
was because affiliate marketing by
saying affiliate marketing
one it's kind of confusing two people
might be like Network more is this an
MLM like what if anything creates
friction or anything makes the viewer
maybe you have
a stigma against affiliate marketing oh
I don't even want to watch I've tried
that before I don't think it works
whereas by pivoting to how to make your
first a thousand dollars in the next 30
days the good thing about that title is
it opens up questions well what is the
method what is the strategy that sounds
interesting and so actually rather than
giving away the the vehicle in this case
could be affiliate marketing another way
to do it could be brand deals another
way to do it could be more monetization
so there's not lots of different ways to
do it but one of the reasons why I
believe performance increased measurably
was actually by making more mystery in
the title and these we can debate these
things endlessly because originally the
the way this was positioned which was
actually I think cooked up by Nolan or
the team and they debate on title crew
was there's nothing wrong with doing
affiliate marketing in the title because
it could be very searchable people are
looking for teach me how to do affiliate
marketing they're aware of that that's
great but then the other opportunity is
they're not aware
of
or the other opportunity is I'm just
looking for all the opportunities teach
me different opportunities and you're
going to avoid creating friction so let
me summarize here's some takeaways the
pivot in the title was broader appeal
because it didn't limit it just to
affiliate marketing it was a clear
promise it actually added as opposed to
make a thousand dollars a month it was
how to make a thousand dollars in the
next 30 days which was it's a very
powerful a specific result in a specific
amount of time and then it removed
friction because again now that
affiliate marketing is not there there's
no friction like I need to figure out
what's on the other side of this title
I what are the ways maybe it's a way I
don't know which at least what are we
talking about how to improve your
improve your CTR your click-through rate
so you're getting the click and now it's
up to the video to deliver on the
results uh ultimately and so that is the
power of changing a title and this is
just part one of this training I'm going
to get into these other parts but I want
to give a shout out to our sponsor vid
IQ uh today and uh you can get a trial
of vid IQ vidiq.com forward slash think
for just one dollar you can get access
to the Boost plan
um and one of the coolest things about
vid IQ is their title tools and so a lot
of times people use the vid IQ Vision
which gives you on the right side of
your screen a lot of data and really
cool resources that are embedded if you
use Google Chrome you install vid IQ
vision and you might as well grab this
too you can always grab the free version
as well but for example one of the cool
things when you're logged into the web
platform is you can get AI title
recommendations so if you actually did
want to talk about affiliate marketing
let's say and you just typed in like
affiliate marketing it's a really
powerful tool to get you started with
some great titles and we're seeing the
power of a Title Here unveiling The
Untold secrets of affiliate marketing
escape the nine to five grind how to
Skyrocket your income with affiliate
marketing and you might say affiliate
marketing for beginners because that's
where your video was going to go that
kind of Direction get title ideas
this uh avoid these five common mistakes
in affiliate marketing ah I should I
should use that one because I've
definitely got five mistakes that I
could teach on so so pretty cool and
that's just one of so many tools inside
of vid IQ and so uh shout out to them uh
bringing you this episode of coffee with
Channel today uh really appreciate vidiq
vidiq.com forward slash thing to get a
30-day trial of vid iq's boost plan for
just one dollar but let's keep it moving
here as we are unpacking the power of
changing the title and improving your
click-through rate and so back to now
now let's fast forward to the future
oh this screenshot was taken yesterday
um you can see the videos that little
it's a little tough to see but there is
a Arc up when I change the title now the
video went to medium performance to a
little bit above average performance
which is cool
um not only that it continues to get
views for weeks now and I think months
and potentially years to come 46 74 new
subscribers 219 dollars all from
changing the title right a big idea and
so at the beginning I talked about these
three things we all need to know in
terms of like really how YouTube Works
how to improve our click-through rate
and a couple things you need to know is
number one
this only works if you're getting
impressions
so some people say Sean should I change
my type they have a brand new channel
they upload a video it gets no view
should I change my title it still gets
no views the problem is if you're not
getting Impressions changing much
anything about it is not going to shift
things that much so essentially for this
to work your channel needs a little bit
of momentum but here's the good news if
your video is getting a thousand
Impressions and I'll show you in a
second how you can see that
and you have a three percent
click-through rate then that's 30 people
clicking
if you change it to a five percent
click-through rate this could be 50
people clicking very powerful so the
next thing is going to be your
click-through rate so if we
the video number one has to be getting
impressions
and I could do some q a later about
anything and this might bring up a lot
of questions
uh then it's going to get a
click-through rate and then also it's
going to lead to average view duration
right and so one of the things you can't
change once the video is out obviously
is the video itself
so the problem is
our ultimate goal is not to put lipstick
on a pig what do I mean
if if the video is always already poor
but you're like man I can make the
thumbnail and title way better well
people still actually have to watch the
video and in some cases
your title and your thumbnail can
improve average view duration
in the sense that if they're more honest
or they're more accurate or they set
expectations better
they actually can increase average view
duration conversely if you like click
bait and you sort of are deceptive or
you don't set expectations well you can
get the click but still your
click-through rate is going to drop
because average view duration suffers
because you trick people to click
but it doesn't actually prove to work
because they don't actually consume the
video
pretty geeky but let's keep it going and
where does this come from so we're going
to go deeper so that you can really make
sense of this
but this comes from YouTube itself in in
like their funnel of how YouTube works
and how we get views it's Impressions
and how they lead to watch time so on
think media in the last 28 days my main
YouTube channel
34.8 percent of YouTube uh or no 43.9
million impressions so again the more
Impressions you have the more these
little tweaks matter
you can see that on average that that
leads to a 7.1 click-through rate and
then ultimately that's how we end up
getting the views so basically can
changing your title or thumbnail get you
more views a hundred percent of for sure
it can and we'll dive into uh more uh
tips and now part two The Power of
changing the thumbnail so in the last
one all we changed was the title which
is pretty cool because that's relatively
easy to change however you may have
noticed you're like oh I didn't know you
went that deep i i brainstormed 10 new
titles to kind of look at the
differences and it is cool it's
especially powerful if you have someone
to debate with this is why people they
actually we launched a new thing called
VRA Elite and why people love our VRA
Elite program because they actually have
someone to talk with uh you know like
I've got Steph and Nolan and Kyle Drea
and so we have like our own little
Mastermind inside of a slack thread like
that's why we realized a lot of people
in our community want to get like
somebody they can bounce titles off
bounce thumbnails off but the second
thing is the power of changing a
thumbnail and in the last couple weeks
uh one pivot I made was this one YouTube
secret changed my life forever this was
a podcast episode this was the original
thumbnail now I think this thumbnail is
pretty good
but here is what made me want to change
it one um it felt the same I was like
this is kind of like the same thing
we've been doing lately
um I get the unlock YouTube thing but
like is that actually super clear
um okay I'm being told us it gets good
actually I can't even critique it it's a
great thumbnail but but here was my
thinking and why I changed it so I
changed it to the thumbnail you can see
in the upper left hand corner which by
the way ended up being
um just a phone photo
right here where I'm sitting recording
this episode
like and that was it shot on my iPhone
set the timer and took the photo now
imagine my office is kind of cool and
I've got some LED lights there and and I
think the big key here is I'm holding a
silver play button
um and that in and of itself would be
the desire so you're tapping into in the
thumbnail like what is this one secret
changed my life a lot of people are
ambitious to get the silver play button
but what you can see here and maybe this
is the one I actually wrote good notes
on or they just did not make it to my
PowerPoint notes so again I want to say
you could see there was a direct
uptick in the click-through rate so if
you're in your analytics you go to the
reach page you can see your impressions
click-through rate so how many
Impressions is the video getting the
click-through rate boosted and again I
want to say this was like a two percent
in uh increase in click-through rate
from 5.5 or 5.3 to 7.3 and boom
thumbnail pivoted that was the only
thing changed not the title and
the uh results were improved so the
takeaways were
audience desire the previous one didn't
have the silver play button in it so
what's the desire of the of the audience
that would be consuming this video the
pattern interrupt every once in a while
there's a good book by
um Seth Godin called like marketers Rune
everything or or he's taught on that
before and what essentially kind of
means is in social media and in content
creation and in marketing a lot of times
people we just do this like something
starts to work but then we just
everybody does it and they do it a lot
and they do it for a long time
so we it stops working
um when it comes to almost anything we
do
there's like even they call it ad
blindness like maybe originally when you
opened up email in high school do you
remember your high school email address
I literally still have mine I have a
Hotmail it's like my main address I'm at
the bank like doing escrow payments true
story like I'm like uh
Sean Hotmail you know and I'm like what
am I 16 like what is happening true
story and maybe you stand up for your uh
your Yahoo email address or whatever
and uh
what's the point I don't even know where
I was going with that it's too funny to
get distracted uh uh
uh audience desire uh pattern oh yeah
um and banner advertising and email so
you've got so you might remember you get
email and email is amazing like oh my
gosh I'm getting emails like you're
emailing you're like high school crush
and you're like this is so cool chat
rooms AOL chat rooms all right and so
ultimately though there was like Banner
advertising right inside of emails
Banners at the top banners of the right
well they call it add blindness because
eventually you get to a place where like
yes there's advertising there but you
don't even see it it just becomes noise
it just becomes well I think that's
important for us to consider in YouTube
as well so one of the reasons why I also
wanted to Pivot the thumbnail and it did
improve click-through rate was I just
wanted maybe our thumbnails have a look
they look a certain way for uh the last
little bit and I was like I just want to
switch it up and it proved to work it
just looked different iPhone only which
I think speaks to the power that your
smartphone is so powerful just learn how
to use it and you can make better
thumbnails
um and ultimately that was the goal goal
with that so the takeaways
was audience desires over play button
the pattern interrupt to like stop
something that's unique and different
that you don't normally see and to stop
the scroll like wait was that a mistake
did he forget to upload these thumbnail
like and that's all the gold then read
the title and again it paid off so in
part one we talked about yes changing
your title can be very powerful in part
two we talked about changing your
thumbnail can also ultimately improve
improved click-through rate and even a
small tweak to your click-through rate
can have big results especially if your
video is getting Impressions and
learning these skills now pays dividends
in the long run because you might be
like my channel is like barely getting
any impressions as it is but you want to
develop Mastery and skills and
excellence in the small things now
because it's like a spiritual principle
too like if you're faithful with little
you'll be entrusted with much so there's
something about like learning like
thinking big in small places acting big
in small places dreaming big in small
places not letting your small YouTube
channel make you small minded but
actually developing the mindset of
Mastery and acting like like what if you
acted like a pro not even Faking It Like
learn the skills of a pro the behaviors
of a pro and you implemented the
behaviors of a pro repeatedly next thing
you know they're like man you're a
YouTube Pro like because it ends up you
know turning into that so let's go into
partner three though and this will get
really interesting
hit like if you've been getting value
and let's talk about the power of
changing a thumbnail and or title of
your best performing videos because this
will apply to more of us
um because you can go back look at your
best performing videos
and let me get to the example I want to
show you here perfect
Okay so
we're going to use this think media
podcast video
um this video was called how to grow
your channel fast with YouTube shorts
and let me make sure I can log into the
analytics here because this is something
you've probably never seen before and
not a lot of people talk about
and so let me tell you the strategy
and then I will show you the results and
show you how you can apply this to your
channel immediately and start getting
better results so here's the three steps
identify an older video that gets views
every month
and if it's one or two weeks old it's
probably not old enough if it's over a
month old or even multiple months old
and it gets views every month thus go to
your real-time views right inside of
your analytics too change one thing
don't do two things at once in marketing
we call this split testing
and in a split test you don't change the
thumbnail and the title you change just
the title you see the results you go
okay cool you make a conclusion then you
could go back and change the thumbnail
but you don't do two things at a time
and in Split testing on like a landing
page of marketing there's like the
headline there could be the copy there
could be the images there could be the
website colors there could be the button
colors when you split test thing there
could be the copy on the buttons you
just change one thing though because if
you change too many variables
and then then it mixes
uh it it dilutes
the data of your conclusion you're like
oh wow it's performing better but you're
not sure why it's performing better so
you isolate one thing so you're going to
identify an older video that gets views
every month you're going to change one
thing the title or the thumbnail and
then you're gonna watch The Impressions
over the next three to seven days so
this was a video this is how I would do
it I went into
think media podcast real time views I
found a video by the way we're actually
talking about making a winner win more
because look this video
is got 81 000 views already the blue
line of view growth is outperforming the
typical performance on the channel
pretty cool it's 138 days old great so
here's what here's now exactly how you
would measure this
so you can go into the video
you can go to reach
Impressions it's gotten 1.3 million
Impressions total across its whole
lifetime it's gotten a 2.9 click through
rate now imagine this imagine if that
was even just 3.1
um 1.3 million impressions that's a lot
more views imagine if that was four
percent on 1.3 so so a small tweaks lead
to Giant Peaks a small tweak to the
click-through rate
can have leads to significantly more
views depending on how many Impressions
a video is getting but Sean how would I
measure
if I change the thumbnail whether it's
been successful or not am I trying to
like put a microscope and see if the
line moves no no there's an actual
mathematical way to do it so what you're
going to do is you're going to go last
seven days
and what you're going to see on a video
like this that in the last seven days
click-through rate was 3.3
and you can see that every single day
the video it has been ranging September
12th when was that September 12th was a
Tuesday
okay so views might even though it's an
old video views might go up it looks
like no Impressions go up when we upload
new episodes and we upload new episodes
on Tuesday that's a hypothesis I'm just
guessing and then they they're a little
bit higher than they dropped the video
also might just be kind of on a decline
so how could we review revive this okay
so let's say we change one thing can I
improve this thumbnail so change the
thumbnail and then wait and you don't
gotta wait a week necessary you might
know in a few hours but then what you're
going to want to see is is YouTube
serving this to more people or less are
Impressions going up or even if
impressions are staying the same as
click-through rate going up so if this
if we change just the thumbnail
and then observe it over three four five
six seven days
and this goes to four and a half
it's
when your mind starts to think I mean
drop an emoji if you're like this is
mind explode because it starts making
you dream like oh my gosh not only is
this video doing this but if I just
change this one thing and it improves
performance
then over time this video might get
thousands of more views so this would be
improving your winner and you can do the
exact same thing with the title
you could change just the title and see
if things stay the same and so what I'm
looking for this the big key is I'm
looking for a video that's getting
consistent Impressions because if the
video is dead and you change the
thumbnail then you're not measuring it
against anything and if the video is
dead here's a mistake you could also
make and you go share it on your
community tab or like email your list to
go watch a video where you're bringing
traffic from external what we want is we
want a video that's getting impressions
based on the YouTube algorithm this is
getting suggested videos is the number
one traffic source and search is the
second traffic source
so it's this is already getting
consistent Impressions change the title
boom Oh sick let's leave it now you
might say well what if it actually goes
down what if the click-through rate goes
down what if impression starts to drop
flip it back just remember what your
prior title was and it'll at least
revert and balance out to what it was
previously
or uh try another one try another split
test another test and what you
ultimately could do
is then see that
um okay cool now I have verified that
this thumbnail performs better and now I
have verified that this title uh after
the thumbnails verified then you could
also do the title as well so that would
be up to you
and so
um as we land the plane this is the
process for doing this you're going to
identify an older video that gets views
every single month change one thing the
title or the thumbnail watch Impressions
over the next three to seven days or
less once you can verify and then you
want to prove your test is right or
wrong you might want to be like okay
cool click-through rate went up
Impressions went up
um then from there you can execute and
uh either revert if you're wrong and no
no harm no foul go back to the previous
thumbnail no harm no foul go back to the
previous title and 80 20 rule would
suggest that you actually making your
best videos win more is probably the
best use of your energy rather than like
going back into your library and trying
to revive videos that are completely
dead or just that have not proven to be
effective at all this takes a little bit
of intuition though because maybe you
realize you made a mistake a lot of
people in our community
kindly said have such bad titles and
thumbnails and positioning and
psychology around their videos that the
video was doomed from the start because
you've titled and thumbnailed it so bad
maybe the content's great I just did
coaching for two hours yesterday uh like
with a higher level group and
these are some very smart people who had
terrible titles and thumbnails so I was
like man we gotta at least get like the
basics right so there's definitely some
opportunity to improve there but even if
they're pretty good and your video is
doing pretty well there could be some
opportunity to improve it if you got
value out of this smash like uh and if
you have some questions we can get to
your questions here
um in a little bit we'll start those and
um I'm sure there's a lot of questions
related to these types of granular geeky
things happy to talk about any of it uh
I want to say cheers we're going to have
Brian on the show here in a second but
coffee with candle
is back and uh
I'm sipping on some Ethiopia coffee from
Presta I believe they're based in
Arizona
this is the coffee with candle show
[Music]
yes Sean Cannell here rhymes with
YouTube channel this is the coffee with
Channel show helping you build your
influence build a profitable YouTube
channel and giving you raw and real
advice especially with the day like
today
um David said I changed the thumbnail on
a video that had a two percent CTR
after 30 to 40 days now 70 days it has a
10 CTR great
story David thanks for sharing that and
again further confirmation
that taking some time to look at your
past videos and improve them
can have a significant impact uh on
uh the future of those videos and that's
a huge jump from two percent for 10 10
great job well I'm fired up for our
coaching session today we have uh the
experimental aircraft Channel coming
back on coffee with cattle it's been
years maybe the pandemic was the last
time we were hanging out so I want to
welcome Brian to the show uh Brian how's
it going great hey Sean good to see you
and hear you again
um fired up to be hanging out and I
think this is going to be a deep
conversation a lot of people are going
to benefit from because I I think I
happened by I want to shout out
everybody in our community
Facebook Twitter I hover around places
our team and I do and we try to get to
as many comments and replies as possible
but I did see your comment and I was
able to reply and be like okay yeah and
you mentioned maybe tell us your
situation you mentioned that views maybe
fall off or you felt like you need to
reinvent or the algorithm is changed and
we're going to kind of unpack maybe some
ways to innovate again and uh but yeah
let us know kind of where you've been
where you are and what's happening sure
thanks uh first off just to share with
everybody though that Sean is watching
because he put up a sponsor dad within
like 30 seconds I commented and he
actually responded back so that's why
we're here talking today but uh yeah uh
we we talked a couple years ago a little
bit more in our Genesis if you will and
here we are we just celebrate our five
year anniversary of launching the
channel it was July five years ago been
doing this full-time for four years now
and what I wrote to Sean is in Biz five
years four years full time suddenly feel
like the whole game has changed
overnight and what I what do I mean by
that is that the views seem to be
hovering around five to 10K
um it seems like the 20 to 30 or 50
000 ones are are gone or something like
that social media post interaction seems
to be down a little bit uh some of our
new trying to gain new sponsors through
um soliciting seems to be slow to
respond
and I just feel like YouTube shines the
Limelight on you whenever it wants and
then goes away
so um a few things to unpack there but
you know basically I feel like after
five years I should I should know more
and have this figured out by now
um being I'm doing this full-time
providing for my family like many of us
are and so forth but I'm just at a loss
Sean I just feel like some maybe the the
goal posts have moved
um I mean I know YouTube is ever
evolving I see the stuff that you share
with your interviews with YouTube and so
forth
um but yeah just trying to to catch up
and stay ahead of the game we are a
super Niche Channel as you imagine with
the experimental aircraft which is uh as
a pro and a con the audience is not as
broad but it's also helped us to to gain
our followers faster because of less
competition all right we're at 155 subs
155k subs now
and uh but I still feel very much like a
small tiny Channel you know I got the uh
the silver play button it's like woohoo
I won you know I got the silver play
button I've actually never displayed it
but I haven't
so um I've been following you since day
one about your YouTube secret uh book or
downloaded download the book and um you
know you're you're on you're in my face
every day as I'm working
um so I want to go to you as my Guru and
be like John help Where Do We Go From
Here Yeah so so many factors uh Brian
and I appreciate and I'm sure a lot of
people can relate with some of the
things you're feeling
um
videos that used to break out more
consistently
it's all relative to each of our
individual channels but you mentioned 30
40 50 000 views of video and now it
seems like those are few and far between
it feels like the whole game has changed
it feels like
um you thought you had you know your
YouTube strategy dialed and now maybe
what used to work isn't working right
now
um and the first thing is you're feeling
the same thing that 99 of creators we
talk to are feeling so you're not alone
and I am seeing this basically platform
wide that
air quotes views are down
um and that it's harder right now
and that breaking through that it feels
like the algorithm change in the game is
changing Number One You're Not Alone
number two
I think we can address
some practical things just for you to
consider
um one
we've seen this happen a lot people who
compare who especially had a lot of
success during the pandemic or started
during the pandemic I don't know if this
is just you but I want to put it out
there sure
um our views doubled during the pandemic
you can go back and look at our 125 000
views a day on think media lockdown
started quarter million we didn't do
anything different quarter million like
just all of a sudden and I was like I
could if my conclusion was I am a genius
now actually I am a genius said humbly
uh but like I was a genius in getting
prepared anybody like if you're sitting
on the sidelines and watching this right
now what makes you look smart is getting
videos out there that are ranked and
that are ready for you never know what's
gonna happen I never could have known
what was going to happen but turned out
I'd been you know uh learning how to
swim for 10 years not realizing the
world was going to get flooded like it
was good that I was prepared for the
flood and
but nevertheless I can't take credit for
the fact that external forces gave
people a lot of time to not just be at
home but also to have specific questions
to start new hobbies to look for new
side hustles and thus our views doubled
overnight well here's what also has
happened though life gets busy again
lockdowns stop people get busy I was
talking to a friend yesterday had soccer
games and three teenagers and all
weekend long so
so there's competing there's lots of
competing things for people's attention
and there's also seasonality so things
to consider when you feel like your
views are going down seasonality like
macro seasonality Global I think another
thing to consider is
um we cannot ignore
competition
and let me Define what I mean I don't
mean necessarily your competitor on
YouTube I mean Kim and Kanye's divorce
on HBO Max I mean
PS5 drops in price and people are doing
air simulators
and going another Direction I mean
the competition for people's attention
across all
Ott platforms across other social media
platforms YouTube is still the dominant
platform but Tick Tock takes a lot of
people's attention and not just young
people
um there's a lot of different podcasts
and video podcasts for people to listen
to
so
the law of diminishing returns
is incredibly relevant here and we're
not just competing internally with other
YouTube channels but we're just
competing in general we're competing
with even maybe other Hobbies pickleball
since we talked last has become a global
phenomenon maybe someone's like you know
what I'm not an aircraft anymore I'm now
a pickleball guy
pickleball paddles and buying so I think
I think a lot of those things are are
something to consider
and I'll share a few remedies from my
standpoint but then I want to address
like this other idea and that is
um
putting things in proper perspective
so what can happen is
a couple years ago when would you say
you felt things shift
like how long has it been since you were
like it felt a little bit easier to get
50 000 views
oh I don't know exactly um maybe a year
ago after the pandemic had kind of
slowed down and so forth where it's like
yeah yeah I feel a little bit like on
cruise control like I got this figured
out
um and I'll admit to you and to
everybody watching you know there is a
point where we are on a weekly upload
schedule right so coming up with content
and ideas every single week for five
years is a as a big
um uh Demand right and I probably got a
little bit of burnout from that
um slightly because you have to come up
with you know a lot of creativity for
for five years
um Instagram post hasn't been as much
um as previous but you know Facebook and
stuff like that is still is still there
um but yes there is a point probably
about a year ago that felt a little bit
more like cruise control
so
one of the things that uh
can happen for us
emotionally
as content creators that have been doing
this for a long time too is it we do get
comfortable we get used to the results
and I actually think we start to get a
little bit delusional here's also what I
mean
so this platform YouTube has given you
the opportunity
for free to build up your brand build up
a personal brand go full time
YouTube is giving you 22 million 553 000
views
um they don't charge you any money
and you've gotten all this exposure it's
completely changed your life you've
gotten all this Joy all these
relationships all of these family this
body of work that has happened and at
one point
let's say you're getting you know a
million views a month
uh compared to what you're getting now
and now it's dropped
let's call it 1.5 now it's dropped to
only
746 views in the last 28 days
and you just came on the coffee with
candle show
to talk about woe is me
life is so hard I mean I'm just giving
you a hard time but think about it right
you came on
I just I mean my Channel's dead
there's no hope it's a famine what's
wrong
my dog died they stole my truck and they
stole my airplane I got a country song
coming out soon got a country song and
so but I mean this is the kind of
perspective so sometimes even haters
like because I'll get haters
um because obviously we teach YouTube
and they'll be like your views are down
and I'll be like yeah everybody's heart
and I'll be like I get it you gotta
innovate you gotta Pioneer but dude I'm
chilling with my three-year-old and my
one-year-old man I mean I'm working hard
but like I'm gonna put this in
perspective I just made a video there
was a it was a clip from a podcast where
I said I'm sorry 40 million views a
month is not enough for you and at the
time we hit 40 million views a month on
think media and somebody was like what
do you know about YouTube I'm like
you're right I'm totally I apologize I
apologize if 40 million views in a month
well I don't know you're right I don't
know anything I was like you know so I
think it's just like putting it in
perspective like people have and of
course not all views are the same there
could be shorts views versus Longs views
there could be the business model behind
there's the RPM of the channel there's
all and that's kind of what I was
getting at it was also the iceberg
underneath it so
summarizing
I think just putting things back in
proper perspective a an adjacent subject
matter is this idea of paid advertising
and
I saw this years ago for those any
business owner that has a product or a
service or a program that isn't
spending at least a thousand dollars a
day in paid advertising has not even
entered into modern marketing like they
don't even understand what is happening
in today's world Henry Ford said the
business owner who stopped spending
money on Advertising is like the man who
tries to stop a clock to save time like
like you should be a business owner
should have marketing dollars it's not
for everybody because not everyone's
selling something they're going ad
revenue patreon or other things
but
99.9 percent of creators don't have that
skill or haven't invested in learning it
or have it built the team and they're
missing out on this major thing but
that's not the point I'm trying to make
the point I'm trying to make
is what people don't understand is that
seven eight years ago
paying for advertising on Facebook meta
Instagram Tick Tock wherever
was so crazy affordable because big
Brands and other
and the maturity of those platforms it
was it was what garyvee would call
underpriced attention
and it goes up over the years four years
ago it was more expensive but still
insane last year it was more expensive
during the pandemic
everyone went on defense and it was one
of the biggest growth years of think
media because we're wartime leaders we
didn't go we didn't like the whole world
got scared locked down and moved in fear
and went on and went on defense we went
in full offense and there was a season
of shockingly underpriced attention and
perceiving that and hitting the gas is
kind of a long story to just make the
one point
it's 2023. ad costs are up but they're
going to be even crazier in five years
and they're gonna be even crazier in 10
years and so
speaking to your perspective and it's a
very good mindset conversation for
everybody in our community
is like even a reframe of you are
killing it like 5 700 views is
phenomenal if you can work out the math
and the economics obviously you want to
get 13 000 and I do have these aren't
even the tips it's just the reframe of
the mindset of
like putting the macro into perspective
that you're getting 800 000 views a
month that you're still impacting people
and that yes numbers have gone down but
pretty much everybody's numbers have
gone down I'm not prescribing
complacency but I am prescribing
contentment it's a weird I think there
could be a tension between we're content
but not complacent that's maybe where I
try to live with just an emotional
Baseline like a resiliency like it's
just like yeah it was it was really cool
when it was like super easy to get 150
000 views but man 25 000 is pretty cool
too I'm gonna keep doing this
um and we keep winning and we keep
winning at a big level because of maybe
just having this grit and I think it's
like framing
if you got that hunger if you know what
it's like to live in famine
then your with any level of abundance
you're happy as a clam and that's kind
of where I sit where people like oh man
it feels like our views are going down
I'm like yeah I guess I mean five
million views a month is still pretty
sick like you know you know and I've
lived through enough seasons and Cycles
where I'm like
another thing's gonna come a lot of
people are gonna probably give up this
is a season where a lot of people are
going to give up so sometimes it's just
you're staying power a lot of people
aren't going to innovate and I'll I'll
kick it back to you before we get into
like a list of tips but a lot of people
are not going to innovate
they're not going to adapt they're going
to be starved out in in some of the
circumstances that are happening here
they're not going to endure any kind of
YouTube recession or famine
thus the opportunity for the people who
stick it through is then we'll be we'll
be back some level where and just one
other quick example like where's this
whole season on Facebook reels where it
was absolute Insanity it was so Bonkers
for us we'd get 55k views 155 225 6
million 5 million 10 million 25 million
um but one of the things I like to
encourage myself while that we're going
through that as I was I was like this
isn't Gonna Last not in some like
negative depressive view or like you
know this is healthy relationships not
gonna I'm just like I I'm not gonna
allow myself to get Intoxicated by the
dopamine of an algorithmic moment
I'm going to keep myself based in just
best practices and best principles I
mentioned it earlier just becoming a pro
and just working just living the
lifestyle and having the habits routines
and disciplines of a pro in any season
and I found that so far that's made us
anti-fragile and we just haven't lost
we've had ups Downs maybe a negative
month in p l on a macro nothing but slow
and steady wins and growth so
That season has slowed down it's nothing
like it was but now our Facebook reels
get two thousand ten thousand fifty five
thousand a hundred and seventy six
thousand sixty thousand one just hit a
million it's a lot more rare so am I
gonna stop well I am if I it was
detoxing too hard off of the drugs uh of
the views of yesterday but I never
allowed myself to get addicted or to get
delusional I'm like this is amazing too
and I can reframe that perspective and
we'll get into some tips what are your
thoughts so far as we've been talking
about mindset
so
yeah a couple of things there one and I
appreciate you obviously spending the
positive side of this and yes Brian's
like are you bragging or complaining I
get we got 155 000 subscribers you have
a following here of like people getting
into YouTube and so forth like gosh I
wish I could be there but it's not like
you get when you get 100 000 views and
you silver play button the YouTube gives
you a raise per video or something like
that right yeah you're you're almost
everyone's still at like the same Level
Playing Field
of every video being judged on its own
merits not your subscribers really not
your history that gives you a little bit
of an edge because there's that initial
distribution every video is being judged
in isolation on its own merits its own
broad appeal its own title its own
thumbnail its own quality of average
view duration back to you
yeah so uh you know what you're saying
here is
the game is is changing a little bit
right or just the ebb and flow of we do
have Peaks and valleys valleys you know
this kind of stuff but um it seemed like
previous years of Peaks and valleys uh
we're a little bit more survival now
with inflation happening that's kind of
offset some of the the peak season right
so what does that mean for me
um you mean inflation like that this is
also infecting the finances of your
Channel
yeah just generally you go to the
grocery store to buy a few your family I
mean that's uh your your gas your car
has gone up here homeowners insurance
has gone up all the stuff has gone up
you know but your uh your income really
hasn't type thing so that kind of
creates an offset that being said
um you know I'll share with you
basically our two incomes are mainly
from Google AdSense and from sponsorship
it's been almost 50 50 right we have not
tapped into the affiliate programs maybe
one or two but they're not really maybe
a 100 200 a month or something like that
um merchandise
um and just other avenues and maybe
that's the time to really deep dive into
that and gaining that because uh you
know we're relying solely pretty much on
either Google AdSense or sponsorship and
if either one of those starts to dwindle
a little bit for several months or a
month then it kind of puts you in a bad
situation
so um if that's one of the things we
need to adopt immediately to try to help
cover those valleys
um the other thing I'd back up a little
bit you're talking about seasonality
let's talk about that for a second this
is like more a general question to you
Sean is that you know comparing this to
TV this is like ancient history now
comparing this to TV there would be a
show that you would love maybe it would
have a pilot it'd be great but it only
lasted the pilot show then there'd be a
show that lasted a couple seasons and
there's a show that gosh it's been on as
long as you and I have been walking
practically you know I mean like the
mash or something like that
um and I went into this and you probably
did as well thinking all right let's be
realistic we could have a good pilot and
that's it or we might have a couple
years and then all of a sudden seasons
change and people lose interest and
that's kind of
I don't have one foot in the door I want
to fit out the door I'm fully committed
but at the same time I'm looking for for
some cues on like uh you know where is
this going can we go through a rough
time or is it the the world is changing
and like as an example what I report on
what I share is getting people into
Aviation and building airplanes which I
admit to you fully in today's world and
economy you're it's basically permitting
promoting playing with toys right
airplanes are toys
yep you know so when it comes down to
bread and butter or airplanes
you know what's going to be uh left over
so anyways just a few things there
let's go
aggressive action items and uh okay and
hit a couple things one more thing and
you mentioned it is I think that we
underestimate audience fatigue
um and maybe it's not just audience
fatigue but audience transition how does
the family vlogger
who attracted an audience
um let me back up how does the Gen Z
vlogger who attracted an audience for
living a lifestyle of traveling and and
kind of living a single or dating life
of all these cool experiences that then
transitions into getting married and
having kids
actually bring her audience along with
her
if
her core audience followed her because
she was going to the club and because it
was that kind of lifestyle and now they
move to Middle America and live on a
farm
the question is does your audience
transition with you or did they
subscribe because they were like I love
the fact that you went to all these EDM
festivals around the world
so there's the maturing and the shifting
of a your your audience I'm actually
talking about too I think about my
friends and co-author of YouTube Secrets
Benji and Judy Their audience have
actually grown with them as they have
grown as well from lots of different
seasons of life but then but talk about
attrition
do people even watch
vloggers anymore did they stop watching
YouTube all together
you have in some incredible insights of
saying when there's some fluff in the
economy
whether it's aircraft or boating or toys
if that slows down then the shift in the
macro Market is going to in
influence your micro market so
so audience transitioning audience
growing up audience getting bored
audience giving up on their Hobby
and so I apply this to think media
audience uh that might say oh you know
what it's just too hard audience saying
I do want to do YouTube uh but I just
literally got hit with a sick parent I
got hit with a new career I got a big
race not a bad thing but kind of golden
handcuffs I actually I kind of wanted
outside hustle because I needed it but
actually in the shifting of the job
thing now I'm making a pretty good
income and you know what I'm not gonna
go side hustle I I now that I got good
insurance and stuff so there's a zillion
reasons why someone might subscribe to
think media and then stop watching or
stop following or unsubscribe and they
could be because
I don't like you guys anymore but more
often they're like
it let people's lives change so that
maybe goes without saying but I think um
it presents some of our our our action
items
I think on a macro four things one of my
mentors taught me that we got to outwork
out learn out strategy strategize and
Outlast the competition we got to
outwork out learn out strategize and
Outlast the competition a couple
vulnerabilities I see for you I think
the fact that you're dependent upon
Google AdSense and sponsorship has been
a vulnerability I would say it's never
it actually can be too late in some
cases for certain things but it's never
too late to
pivot and transition but while you were
in the good times lesson for the past
uh you want to be like Joseph in the
Bible storing away grain in seven years
of prosperity for the seven years of
famine and that would be diversifying
income streams I'm not suggesting you
were like saving or investing but again
why things are good build the next thing
um and that next thing could be very
much out of the box a lot of creators
are funding
YouTube creators have a season of
prosperity and they use the dollars to
start investing in airbnbs and something
like that I'm not suggesting you get
that distracted but it's a great it's a
good point another way to consider it
would be uh you know the business models
of course are like courses or uh
coaching programs but I think for you it
could be some kind of an experience of
like you take on 10 students and help
them build their plane you help them you
you make an offer to a very affluent
group of people well like that might
require staff it might require some
different things but if you have the
right person that wants you the expert
holding their hand of 10 very affluent
people that would love for you to walk
them through the building of some kind
of custom plane this is up to you to
understand your Market see the
opportunities in the market and realize
you previously maybe have would not have
been able to launch that but you can now
and by necessity you may need to now
it's it's diverse crucification of
income streams and that's why maybe
going into Airbnb is
or real estate in general is a toll it's
almost in a way it could be a Wrong
conversation I would say within your
business like what opportunities within
your business
um so that you're not dependent on that
because let's also just clarify that for
any business owner
most business owners the majority of
businesses
there's a lot of things they could
suffer from one could be that they don't
their product does need to improve you
know their problem to the solution needs
their answer to the solution needs to
improve
but 99 of people I run into
their problem is actually exposure
nobody knows them they don't have any
leads they don't know how to actually
get in front of people it's one thing to
have a world-class offer it's a whole
other thing to actually get leads for
that offer
when I look at the fact that you're in
front of 791
746 people a month
your problem is not Expo like 99 of the
business owners in the world would kill
for a fraction of this exposure so it's
sort of thinking that like your problem
and a lot of things that YouTube
creators don't understand the
opportunity they have
is what other income streams could you
have and that takes a lot of hard work
and and a lot of you know dialing in an
offer of some kind and or
um you could look at our our think media
podcast episode from today is a must
listen with Jay Dharma Wong said but I
think she was talking about a presenting
sponsor it was actually like a sponsor
of her show
for a whole season like going into
launching a new podcast she got a
sponsor so the the biz Dev I wrote that
down like the business development of
you getting on the phone talking to some
Brands partnering with the company
acquire a company buy half of another
company and growth hack that company
with your thing earn into it
um what company wishes they had 791 000
views a month and you bring the
influence they have this you together
creates a multi-million dollar
opportunity that would be a business
development strategic that's why it's
Out Workout learn out strategize and
Outlast it's a strategic level of
thinking about what's your next
Innovative campaign because the traffic
is still amazing but if we if we get to
myopic and say
well Google AdSense and sponsors are
down we got to get those up or else
we're gonna be out of business
there's
that is that that is not the only two
things we need to solve for in the book
decisive we learn to attain distance
before deciding so we need to get I
would go way zoomed out
um and
and I know those are kind of vague
statements but really I would be after
okay in if if the hill gets steeper I'm
gonna work all the harder I'm going to
outwork
um I don't you are here learning
obviously we're talking but I don't know
maybe things have been good for a while
how aggressive have you been in
investing in
books
courses coaching or buying tickets to
events to get outside of your world and
I don't even necessarily mean directly
for YouTube I mean industry events
marketing fresh ideas you know and then
out strategize have you gone into the
war room with you yourself your team
anybody involved after maybe Gathering
some Intel of what the state of the
world is and getting in front of a
whiteboard and talking about all kinds
of different things and then out last is
again if you just weather the storm and
the storm could be very long as you
probably know like the storm interest
rates like fluffing the economy it might
not be back be back for a while but this
whole thing of the number one goal in
business is to stay in business if you
just don't die for five six seven years
and then there's by default you win by
default because it even dropped to 300
000 views a month but then you've been
around your super seasoned you're ready
to go a bunch of films come out some
viral Tick Tock Trends and all of a
sudden this aircraft thing just blows up
and your position to 10x because
similarly you were you were treading
water
while the world was flooded and you were
able to then last 40 days and 40 nights
and then boom the flood recedes and
you're ready for a whole new season a
blessing so
um it's a Days of Thunder
um clip right where there's there's a
crash and there's smoke on the uh on the
racetrack and he's starting to lift off
the throttle and then instead he goes
Full Throttle through the smoke and
comes out the other side and gains a
position right yeah yeah and so uh I've
said I've said a lot um and I do have
one I have some specific YouTube
strategies but any thoughts on outwork
out learn out strategize and Outlast
no you bring up a good point as far as
you know us YouTubers or whatnot uh we
work a lot from home or close to home at
least and our water cooler discussions
center around our our wife
or whatnot so you know getting outside
the box a little bit I guess that's the
thing is like
I don't know
we share stuff with the world we have a
family of hundreds of thousands of
people whatnot but at the same time we
don't we don't share this behind the
scenes struggle with pretty much anybody
right because it's uh it's your own
personal business plus there's
competition and let's face it all of us
we're in business of attention whether
it's fishing like your Bass Pro Shops
hat
um or boating or or
um airplanes it's all about winning
attention and we're all competing on
that same field whether whatever genre
it is right
um so yeah I think maybe like you're
saying just
who you surround yourself with and
getting new fresh ideas or books or
whatnot and maybe it's time to step back
in into that a little bit but I want to
bring up a point you talk about a lot in
your your different shows is that
especially for newer channels is that
small channels
um you know think that they're small but
they can they can run a full-time
business off those small channels and
maybe for at least a season I need to
operate as if somebody with only 25 000
followers or 50 000 followers and Max
that out to
to kind of uh gain regain some territory
and yeah like a small Channel mentality
it's the underdog mentality yes
that's for sure I mean never losing
that's the scrappy mentality and willing
to to go back get in the dirt as you are
but sometimes it's a hard pill to
swallow when we're used and there's
fatigue that sets in you've been doing
this that's a whole other conversation
for like a future coffee with candle is
what are the emotions and uh physical
toll and mental toll of doing this one
two three four five six years of trying
to reinvent
um there's no doubt about it there's
some you know legit kind of fatigue and
so reshifting our mindset to get back
into that gritty upstart startup
mentality Underdog mentality right right
yeah okay so here's uh I'll I'll kick
we'll land the plane with one thing nice
long conversation today coffee with
candle let us know what your aha moments
have been
um and and you know this conversation is
so relevant for all of us there's been
lots of nuances uh and that's why we're
here for you so it's definitely smash
the like button and maybe share this
with somebody that
um
you know needs to hear this a Creator
friend or somebody else because the good
news is there is hope I mean the good
news is that
it's always going to be a small
percentage that actually does outwork
out learn out strategize and Outlast and
because of that there's still hope for
all of us if we put in the work if we
summon the courage summon the energy
rally our vision again and also put in
the put in the the work necessary to
upskill up level
um when things get tough when the going
gets tough the tough get going and
that's our community at the think media
podcast and coffee with Channel
I just uploaded 16 new videos
um more than that but it's 16 kind of
modules inside of our video ranking
Academy course this is in our VRA
masters section of VRA and it's under
this prom premise uh Brian and that is
that when people are creating
uh content they get stuck in ruts of I
do talking head videos I do kind of a
vlog style of a plane or whatever you
know I do
um I answer specific questions kind of
search based as we've taught a lot of
you know I review specific products you
mentioned not doing affiliate marketing
but it actually could be an opportunity
because uh maybe there are people
looking for actual specific parts and
they build that and you've got links Etc
so I think that after all this is said
and done because we've talked a lot
about mindset stuff I also it's probably
one of the most tactical episodes of
coffee with Channel
um I know this
99 of creators are usually like a one or
two trick pony
and and video record Academy we are
training people to be to have at least
16 tools and then we go into that
there's even more than that meaning
you're trying to build a YouTube Empire
and people are either using a hammer or
a screwdriver and that's it but they
didn't realize that there's also a saw
that there's also a jackhammer which is
a whole other if you don't have that
power tool you it's going to be real
tough to break up that concrete which is
the traditional Hammer so we get a lot
of frustrates so so what are these so I
think that we obviously don't have time
to get into them uh but but uh different
ways to get outside of the box some of
the core ones we teach answer specific
questions oh it's still good review
specific products teach specific skills
how to do X build a plane in your case
you know whatever Trend surfing I think
there could be some stuff tying into
Trends tying into the news tying into
something uh influence surfing I saw Mr
Beast and it looked like the guy that
you he was in your thumbnail because the
little plane they had for one of their
videos and yeah is that amazing that he
he saw the video and called the contact
that I had and made a whole other video
about that that was like you could have
called me I could have introduced you
but you know and it was that was a such
a great example and this was a video I
saw I mean maybe to close the loop here
because people think just so uh visually
you could see people think oh am I just
trying to like follow Trends and jump on
influencers well no I mean if if it's
relevant to your Niche meet the pilot
Breezy aircraft pilot Libby flew Mr
Beast
that is directly tied into this channel
so you're not just trying to be trendy
you're actually surfing on relevant
influence related to your industry but
then you can go deeper long form videos
using the skyscraper method React videos
I think there's a big opportunity for
you to react to a lot of different
things that are happening look at react
channels Mr Beast reacts YouTube shorts
uh video podcast that's an interesting
could there's an idea of starting
another Channel I'm not suggesting you
do that I'm just saying when you think
outside of the box we also call can call
this zero based thinking or zero based
strategy where when you're trying to
solve a problem we get so close and we
think
sponsors and AD Revenue as opposed to
let's go zero based what does zero based
mean it means let's
right when we were starting from zero
how would we build what team would we
build how would we manage money what
business model would we build would we
who would we hire how do we structure it
let's just assume we had all the time in
the world or all the the money in the
world or resources what videos would we
make if we watch other channels not just
in your industry from a zero based lens
that would mean okay how has the
platform shifted how can I reinvent
again the people who went out strategize
video so you maybe start a video podcast
interviews is there other Pilots is
there famous pilots uh strategic content
repurposing content marathons uh
faceless videos it's that's usually a
niche like a channel automation channels
and I don't suggest you go that way but
there could be different you could you
can pull
we've we do all of these we have done
all of these at least once at think
media so we do faceless videos even
though we are not a YouTube animation or
automation or faceless channel the
curation strategy that's like the Rob
Dyrdek strategy they have in Carmichael
strategy uh Community live streaming
Evergreen live streaming and then
unlimited possibilities and we actually
in some of the modules talk about 50
more things so all of that is
uh maybe was like a fire hose to say you
can enter you can innovate your videos
sure and I would encourage you that
waiting for you on the other side of
innovating your videos is
can be seasons of New Growth New Growth
the fact of the matter is is as much as
maybe the majority arguably of views
going down a little bit there's channels
that's views are going up but they have
to adapt right and
we have learned and that's why we have
launched this whole section in our
program is that this is what it that is
what adapting looks like when you get
out of the rut of like I've just been
doing talking head videos and I'm
willing to learn new skills Embrace new
content formats and up the production of
my videos the positioning of my videos
the perfect video recipe of my videos
all of you above then waiting for me on
the other side of that is New Growth new
subscribers
um and new breakthrough
yeah
um one quick question before you jump
off if we have a minute
um talking about
um you know staying within our Niche
right
um and I think you are proof of this and
you talked about this in the past I did
start another channel uh back during
covid uh podcast I figured you know
people can't travel and don't want to be
in person so let's do something on the
Internet that being said I feel like
YouTube this is how I describe it right
we had TV which was like 24 channels and
and you had to spread apart this stuff
within 24 channels then we had cable
which is 300 channels of nothing's on
and now we have YouTube which is
infinite right so if you have an idea of
doing something you super Niche down on
that if you have a new idea start a new
channel
and don't go too broad because people
tuned in to you for one thing correct so
you really kind of to stay in your lane
would you agree
well totally agree I don't think you
should start doing Minecraft
playthroughs or gardening videos
um I think the question is to ask is
what did people originally subscribe for
and never upload videos they didn't
subscribe for I think that a missed
opportunity for a lot of people though
is that more views will come from
broader appeal
there's broad appeal ideas that Aviation
enthusiasts would love
that would be the key what broad appeal
topics and content could I cover
incomplete question if we don't add on
that Aviation enthusiasts would love
boom there's a formula for more views
because for sure if you Niche down too
much you're gonna have Niche Hughes not
a bad not bad we talk about very
specific search based videos very
specific affiliate monetizing videos uh
you know because they rank or they just
really solve a very specific thing
but if it's a matter of Top Line views
and I would challenge you Brian that
the quality of the answers that we get
are deter is is predicated on the
quality of our questions
and so
if your question is Sean how do I get
more views
then bro One Way besides the 16 things
we mentioned is broader appeal to
Aviation enthusiasts but but the
additional questions we asked I would
argue are maybe even more important
what offer could I create to make more
views unnecessary exactly
what exactly where is the puck going and
how can I skate to the puck
um yeah what sponsor what presenting
sponsor could I acquire that would be
by jumping on the phone or you know
flying and meeting up with somebody
a Biz Dev startup you know maybe that
you know whatever in the aviation
industry
um that uh in a it could be a seven
figure partnership
these are questions nobody's asking
everybody is asking how do I get more
views on YouTube so I can get a little
bit more ad Revenue which we're here to
help and I love the question and it is a
great question I don't think it's the
most important question no I agree
that's what I was asking like also what
other lanes right so the other streams
can happen here because I don't want to
rely I want to I want to be master of my
own destiny up up to you know God's
control of my destiny and truth right
but what I'm allowed to have in control
of my life I want to have better control
of that right well every smart
entrepreneur is thinking the same thing
yeah and you're and and I love this has
been a great conversation very high
level strategic conversation anything
else Brian as we land on the plane and
now hey I appreciate you and your team
and I follow you all the time and I want
to be more like you that's that's what I
want to be like well that's I appreciate
your kindness so grateful we got to
reconnect and I knew as soon as you
asked the question over on Facebook I I
knew that this conversation would be
rich
and add value to our entire community so
I know everybody here is thankful can
everybody shout out Brian and say uh
thank Brian for being on hey appreciate
you
well thanks again your team and what you
do there
um this is your your ministry away from
your ministry
I love it that's that's how we feel as
well in fact we just finished up our
core values finally we uh clarified him
I don't let me see if I can do them from
memory the Bible is our blueprint uh we
are Purpose Driven leaders uh we are
pursuing Mastery
um love above all
um resilient spirit and I don't know if
I said all six uh but uh and now you
have to teach all that to your children
yeah yeah that's yeah our son turns
three here in a sec in tomorrow
um and uh so really pumped did I hit all
all six this is the first time Bible's
our blueprint pursuit of Mastery built
to last
Purpose Driven love above all resilient
Spirit six core values of course we've
been living them but we wanted to codify
them this year and so we've been moving
towards that process reading the book
the advantage by Patrick lancioni white
organizational Health trumps everything
and uh it's been uh it's been fun but
anyways Brian I'm going to answer some
of the questions here thanks again for
jumping on sounds good thanks Sean
coffee with candle
um I need some aha moments that was a
rich conversation a long conversation
let me know
um what your aha moment your takeaway I
see a lot of love for Brian in the chat
and uh if you're here on the replay and
you're this deep in the video respect
hashtag replay fan drop that down in the
comments
reflay fam uh is serious dedication
um I also want to encourage you for
those of you in our video ranking
Academy family to dive into
your VRA masters section I know the
world's busy I know there's a lot of
things to watch listen to but there is
some brand new deep dive material for
you
um and we go super deep into each of
those 16 Surefire video ideas haven't
taught those in depth anywhere else
we've touched on like the first five in
like different YouTube challenges and
stuff
um but there is so much
um opportunity waiting for you on the
other side of rethinking your strategy
on the other side of being zero based
what if I was starting from scratch
um it's also painful so I admit that
sometimes you're like oh man learn new
skills get out of my comfort zone the
way I was doing it was working now it's
not you know it could be uncomfortable
but I want to encourage you that
um
that waiting for you on the other side
of out strategizing and out learning
others
um is a lot of growth and could be the
next best season for your Channel
Dinesh asks uh we need to change AI
voice over artists in every video or go
with only one in the videos
um
I think that that is completely optional
for you
AI voiceovers are getting really good
if you're starting from scratch on a
channel and you want to get monetized
I've heard stories of people using AI
voiceovers not getting monetized
I've heard that soon AI will be so good
YouTube might not be able to to detect
it
I've also then considered that
on depending on what kind of content
you're creating
a lot of times faceless and automation
channels are just going for one breakout
video and the vulnerability of the
channel is they're not actually building
a brand meaning no one's falling in love
with the voice because someone's just
searching or YouTube suggesting a
breakout video The Voice on it's good
enough
but it's not a personal brand
there are channels who use their own
voice and you they're not on camera but
you do build a connection with them so
these are all things to consider should
you change it
maybe if you're testing to see which one
works best but there's a 36 other
variables right in a video
um and back to you know it's a good
question but back to asking other
questions what's your big strategy what
do you hope this channel to accomplish
are you trying to build a brand are you
just trying to get lucky on a few videos
uh YouTube ads automation Arbitrage game
of
if I get a couple videos I get a couple
thousand dollars a month I don't think
it even matters you're just trying to
get a couple breakout videos paying you
ad Revenue
which I don't want to speak down to that
but it's not necessarily a long-term
Vision it's just a short-term
way to earn side income
and in that case
it doesn't matter so lots of things to
think about I'm super grateful for the
question
um what are you drinking right now I'm
going to take a sip of coffee here
um and uh I'm going to uh be back in
just a second did you know that we have
a weekly show called The think media
podcast if you want to learn the best
strategies for growing your business and
brand with YouTube for how to thrive as
a Creator or how to get more leads and
clients and customers as an entrepreneur
and I want to invite you to subscribe to
the think media podcast available on
YouTube and all of the audio platforms
on this show you're gonna find Advanced
strategies for understanding YouTube for
building the business mechanics around
your YouTube channel including your
email list or taking what you know and
turning it into profitable products we
have amazing guest interviews and all
kinds of special surprises that happen
consistently on the think media podcast
so to get access for free just click the
link in the description or go to
thinkmediapodcast.com
welcome back to the coffee with Channel
show I saw someone uh I saw Drea saying
we need to drink more water and so
I'm with you Drea I'm also sipping on my
uh Presta Ethiopia single origin coffee
here
and answering your questions on the
coffee with kennel
show I see that we've got uh we've got
coffee always my man that's
coffee has water in it yeah that's true
we got some Kool-Aid in the house we got
some water in the house probably smart
drinking water for a change
polishing off a Monster energy drink I
love it um we're out here stay hydrated
though and coffee is a diuretic so
compensate with water is it best to have
the same title and thumbnails on all
videos for those searching
my answer I don't fully understand the
question but my answer is no
like if you're if your YouTube channel
has all the something same titles and
all the same thumbnails that's a bad
idea
um
if you're asking should the thumbnails
kind of look the same so people
understand your brand I've heard
Arguments for that
I don't think there's a proven
your brand could be your face you know
like you follow somebody and if you see
their face you're like oh yeah I
recognize them I watched that person's
show you know or I love their content of
course your brand could be colors some
people put a little logo in the color in
the corner
but
here's my macro answer
it's best to have the best title and
thumbnail for the individual video so
the individual video
can be a banger on YouTube
yes there's building your brand in your
whole library but your whole Library
doesn't matter if you have no breakout
videos so it's attention to be managed
but I want a really good title and a
really good thumbnail and really good
content on one video because every video
is ultimately going to be judged on its
own merits individually
am I recording my classes I am recording
my classes is it okay if I upload to my
channel well I'm not a legal expert I
don't know what the local I mean it is
did you sign a document is there an NDA
is it like an elementary school are
parents okay with it does it even matter
because it like because there's nobody's
likeness in it it's just you do you have
the rights to that material
um I am not giving you permission
um but you might but it but it's a
brilliant question to ask because
anybody
who is already teaching somewhere
um talk about high leverage get a camera
turned on you know get it captured any
business leader that's doing staff
meetings
um that is
coaching your team coaching an
individual individual uh teaching uh
passing on information to somebody doing
a client meeting if you can get
permission to record it you know the big
idea here
um is don't create content be the
content
so I could sit down and be like okay let
me let me talk let me I'll make a video
about leadership or I could turn on a
camera like this camera over here I
could record an angle like this as I'm
doing a zoom meeting and I could deliver
uh a one-on-one
leadership conversation to someone on
the think media team and then upload
that
and thus I would be just being the
content I wouldn't be actually like
creating content I'd be capturing in my
life and a lot of entrepreneurs that are
maybe more established uh because they
have resources they that's the idea of
hiring somebody to follow you around or
hiring someone to help you do that uh
but we've got many videos on our think
media channel Omar's and many where if
you build a battle station like this and
you set up an angle off to the side then
that angle
um or a little bit more centered you
know sometimes just slightly off the
different ways to set it up then you use
that and a lot of times you're going to
use that for shorts
vertical videos on other platforms but
you're not going to go out and create
content you're going to be the content
so if you're teaching in a classroom
great do your due diligence to get
permission and to figure out if you're
allowed to use it but I definitely would
lean into that my Channel Africa V1 is
two and a half months old and I've
noticed that good performing video
suddenly stop having views after 24
hours I wonder why it's pretty common
YouTube
is quite a generous platform
you might notice with shorts there's
like a it has like this Spike and then
it just drops and you're like what
happened did YouTube break my video
or you might notice that
even at a specific time literally 24
hours it drops the reason why is because
the
feedback signals that YouTube is
measuring
average view duration click-through rate
as they show impressions as they show
that video to other people
um compared to other videos on the
platform
so there's an interesting if you
download the YouTube studio app it gives
you like like this little uh box that
like tells you things it'll say like
your average view duration for your
videos is before is between four minutes
and 30 seconds and five minutes and 30
seconds the top 10 percent of videos in
your Niche or the top 10 percent of
videos on YouTube is like a minute
longer than that
so as YouTube is deciding different
content to surface the cool thing about
YouTube because y'all might be like
and YouTube's mean to me it doesn't like
me it's not showing me well YouTube is
not in a way doesn't even care about you
cares about viewers it actually wants to
satisfy viewers
so YouTube is incredibly generous and
the fact that it will give new creators
the opportunity to be seen But then
you only get one shot do not miss your
chance to blow because opportunity comes
once in a lifetime yo
right So after 24 hours if your
click-through rate is four percent I'm
making these up four percent and your
average view duration is two minutes
and other videos that YouTube is
surfacing from other creators their
click-through rate is six percent and
their average view duration is three
minutes then it just might kill you your
views and keep letting that video go and
then that video might go up and up and
up and up so it's it's really what's the
remedy
improve your content watch this
beginning of this coffee with candle
pivot your title and thumbnail if
necessary uh so that it's getting
continues to get good click-through rate
and ultimately good watch time I mean
that's the main metric they want time on
platform they want people watching as
much YouTube as possible I have created
a new YouTube channel for qriket gaming
uh to get more views and followers
how do I get more views and followers
quickly I appreciate the question I'm
going to recommend you
um
uh subscribe to the channel listen to
the podcast because it's super broad
just how do I get views how do I get you
know followers uh
follow think media
um and of course we've got some deeper
resources but we have a ton of free
resources and so I would recommend that
you know one thing a lot of people don't
know about is our 21 video tips free
training and so let me show you that I
would definitely recommend this this is
some strategic uh
kind of tactics that a lot of people
aren't sharing
um and so check this out if you like
content like this then you definitely
want to go to
21videotips.com where you're going to
get 21 amazing tips from entrepreneurs
like Patrick that David Vanessa Lau Pat
Flynn and so many more also Alex or
mosey's in there as well where you're
going to be learning some of their
little known business secrets and inside
of this resource we're giving you a
downloadable guide that goes along with
it to help you get impact right away so
go to
21videotips.com right now to get that
free resource and this incredible video
that has 21 amazing tips from special
guests just like this
[Music]
yeah so let me know if you've already
watched that that's like an hour long
there's a downloadable guide it's
totally free
21videotips.com definitely check that
out one of my videos went viral for me
hit almost 2 000 views but I can't get
back to those views again is that
typical
the after you've seen a video do well
you want to follow up we say success
leaves Clues make part twos you want to
follow up not with a duplicate video but
with an adjacent video what topic went
viral for me how can you double down on
that topic and maybe turn it into a
series
um what can you learn from it but then
it also it could be typical because
sometimes it's hard to replicate success
this is one of the reasons why we have
uh launched our VRA Elite program which
is like group coaching
um where we now have to think media
certified coaches because it's also hard
to sometimes
see
like
observe our own content from an
objective standpoint because what you
also want to do is you want to
architect you want to um pull out the
principles if you you
meaning you go I don't know why this
went viral that would be the big
question to to figure out what about it
and vfm viral for me so you could keep
doing two thousands three thousands four
thousands two thousand eighteen hundred
fifteen hundred twenty three hundred and
and replicate success uh you know some
people say experience is the best
teacher
it's not true experience is not the best
teacher evaluated experience is the best
teacher we have to become Masters at
analyzing not just YouTube analytics but
analyzing content analyzing our audience
retention curve analyze analyzing
feedback signals analyzing the topic
listening to comments thinking about
viewer psychology
experience is not the best teacher
evaluated experience is the best teacher
because when you mine not just general
success principles but your own formula
for your own Niche and your own content
and then you repeat success a lot of
people have accidental success and they
don't know how to repeat it the key is
to reverse engineer
what activities and details and
strategies and tactics and nuances of
that video led to those results
make some hypotheses publish new content
implementing those details and those
nuances and then go wow I got another
2100 another 2400 that would be what I
would recommend
how do you balance creativity with video
number volume I desires to grow the
channel but I often question video
number uploads versus quality efforts
uploading talking head with b-roll Clips
this is a matter of my audience but uh
wow that was long so I'm going to
recommend uh the cool thing is
um I really appreciate the question
we'll link this in the show notes in the
description but
12 days ago at the time of this live
stream we did a video called quality
versus quantity which is more important
um we could I could riff for a long time
I but I would just point you to this
video quality versus quantity which is
more important that was the think media
podcast episode thanks so much uh for
the question and uh my best answer is
right there labor can I flip my channel
and open a second one same content but
if a different language to reach an
audience who doesn't speak English yeah
you can Mr Beast is a good example of
this
um his his videos are being translated
at a high quality level
completely remixed local talent people
with a good accents watch this
jokes are changed cultural references
that would only be stood in the USS are
changed to
uh cultural references or jokes or slang
that would only be that would be
understood in the country with which or
the language which which they're
remixing the content into it world-class
sound design world-class voice over
dubbing world-class music world-class
all of the above and
he's crushing it at a beast level
the real question becomes is this
relevant for the smaller and mid-sized
creator
and then the real question is is it
sustainable financially viable and worth
doing
and then the real next question is
for the good news is I was just at
VidCon spoke at VidCon our interview
today we have eight interviews coming
out over the next
four weeks of uh really good
conversations from VidCon on the think
media podcast
there is a lot of companies
building AI tools to remix our like
let's say English speaking videos into
other languages at a high level
but they're really not there yet
there's AI dubbing because you could
always hire a voiceover artist but
there's the cost
and then there's
the question of how big is your Niche
how good's the content and there's a lot
of different variables
my prescription labor law with Ali is
that chances are
I mean you have 819 subscribers
that this is not
the best
use
of your energy
now don't let me talk you out of an
opportunity that you see if you see a
gap in the market you see
a blue ocean
watch a summary video of the blue ocean
a book summary of The Blue Ocean
strategy book
if you see a blue ocean then maybe you
should pursue this but here's what I've
learned
if
you're not
full time yet
whatever that would mean for you with
your main thing
avoid getting distracted with another
thing
if you're not full time with one YouTube
channel avoid getting distracted with
the second YouTube channel
and a lot of times
that your business theory is sound
but the timing is off
should I ultimately dub or change my
content into another language to expand
my audience and reach a new market
well an infinite time Horizon with
infinite resources the answer would be
yes but we don't have either of those
things we're trying to find the shortest
path to revenue
so my question would be what is the best
language best Channel best topic best
content and shortest path to Financial
Freedom
or escape velocity so that you can focus
on full YouTube full-time or whatever
your goals are
and I would hyper focus on that
and then once there's an abundance of
resources
Financial Human Resources team time
then you could expand one of the biggest
things that kills
like brick and Border businesses or food
and beverage businesses is they expand
into too many markets too fast
right
oh we have one store it's crushing it
now we have seven stores in the city
they're crushing it okay let's take over
the West Coast great now let's go
Nationwide boom company goes bankrupt
of course you could do that successfully
but it's Pace distribution team culture
so it's just it's at what pace do you
scale so if you're saying
you know one channel pace
quality of content consistency of
content consistency of brand consistency
of business model building the business
model the time it takes to fulfill on
the business model around the channel
and then
now I'm gonna try to run three other
channels well
get your shortest path to revenue
get escape velocity with your finances
and then reinvest those finances into
perhaps more languages Mr Beast has
escaped velocity
he's got money and he's got money from
diverse income streams sometimes you
hear his content business just loses
money
but not really because feastables the
chocolate bar
covers all and as content lifts the
brand of feastables so he's able to like
Arbitrage finances from all over and and
cross because again oftentimes overspend
on one video but then also if you
overspends on one video
and then dubs that video into multiple
languages multiplied by 6 to 12 months
boom so he's got enough cash to float
the projects
all right good question
uh Sean can I get I get great views on
shorts but not long form what will help
me transition views from short form to
long form
so one of the things we need to see
friends and this is probably not good
news idiot craft man
but
the million dollar question is
how do I transform
the million dollar question is how do I
transition short form viewers into my
long form content well there's an
analytic that you need to see and if you
go to analytics overview content and at
the top make sure you're selected all
you'll scroll down there's this thing
that says viewers across formats
and you can then see what percentage of
my viewers watch my videos versus my
lives views versus my shorts
so on this particular Channel think
media podcast 76 of people watch videos
only so this is a long form Channel
and
for those 76 that's basically eight out
of ten don't care that I upload shorts
on this channel
okay 12 due so one out of ten do but
check it out one out of ten people on
think media podcast Channel don't make
it to the long form they only watch the
shorts
and then one out of ten watch both
so I think one of the things that we
need to
if you will give up on
is the idea of now I don't we shouldn't
give up on the idea but this whole idea
of that shorts viewers are gonna conform
uh convert to long form I think that
people overestimate they try to force it
they try to do commercials they try to
say go watch long form video they try to
do a lot of stuff and it's there's a lot
of friction in that world now I do have
a second tip for you though and
um let's actually do this live together
because I needed to update this
so we released a video and this video is
a short on how you can save money on
your taxes why is it important to have a
LLC and I want to say
um
there was one of these shorts it's not
this one let me see if I can find the
one that it is so we could do this
together we can do it to all of them
so we had an episode with prime
Corporate Services how an LLC can save
you maybe it's this one
okay great so
um let's see the comet says
uh what source advice make an in-depth
video on this topic so Chris is asking
for an in-depth video on this topic now
interesting is Chris
didn't
I'm not putting Chris down but he did
not
assume even that there was an in-depth
like so this is a clip of a video
podcast and I think this reveals a big
truth we all need to understand
people are not going to go dig up the
long form video they don't necessarily
know there is a long form video and
conversely or as a result
uh
you got to maybe do some hand-to-hand
combat or it shows that the the
connection's kind of broken in a lot of
ways
there's the user not understanding that
the user not willing to be going to
learn look YouTube does say they're
building bridges okay but there is a new
feature that allows you to solve this or
at least to help so what you can
actually do is you can go into the short
itself which is here's that short and he
says is there a long form video
and you could go over on this right side
and I'm glad that Steph is here because
this is something we're going to go back
and do to all of our relevant shorts
um or Drea and it says related video
this is kind of cool so you now have an
area where you can do a related video
and you can connect to a YouTube short
the full length
video so let me see if I can scroll to
it and I don't remember what this video
is called
and this is a this is a practical way
you know shorts also remove links so
this is a cool tactical way that um you
know clickable links in the pinned
comments and description but at least
you can take someone from a short to the
full length video now
a little bit easier so don't get sued uh
legal advice on taxes so here's the full
length video
with
uh Tommy from Prime Corporate Services
I'm going to take this YouTube link
I'm going to come back over here
I'm going to connect that I'm going to
click save
and now
where Chris is saying hey did you do a
full-length video on this topic this
video is now connected to a little
clickable link right here that says
don't get sued and if people click that
from the YouTube short it takes them to
the full length conversation this is a
big deal for
um
anybody that's doing clips from a video
podcast anybody that's doing I should
say shorts yeah Snippets short video
YouTube shorts from any kind of long
form content now you've just connected
the two did you see how that worked now
this is also another clip from that
so if we go back to any of the in fact
tomorrow as well so I'm going to go
details I'm going to go
related video and I'm going to link that
back so I'm going to click save
so now all these different YouTube
shorts with Tommy can link to the full
length video
and
on a macro this is kind of exciting
we'll have to study to see how well this
works
or see see the results and then here I
would I'm not trying to say this is like
you know Gonna Save everything or be the
ultimate
you know thing that crushes it like
because it's still going to be up to the
viewer of the short to understand that
future but it makes it again easier now
for them to just go how having an LLC
can save you seven thousand dollars in
taxes
okay and it says don't get sued little
note so now even the title and it's got
a little title little title play button
right there but
it's kind of confusing you're like okay
I mean actually it's kind of powerful I
guess don't get sued what but now you're
apparently when we have 15 characters of
text
and that's gonna be the first 15
characters of your title which is
something to consider but pretty cool so
now we've got all these YouTube shorts
uploaded that we can enhance let me give
you another coffee with candle tactic
lots of blessings coming out at 12 50.
p.m on a Tuesday on this coffee with
candle show live smash like if you're
grateful and sipping on your
green tea
um
this is a different tactic but we are
doing Clips on this channel we're
testing them we're seeing how good
they're doing
but we did like this clip from Neil
dingra
and I wish I was logged in with my think
media account so I didn't have to watch
ads because I have premium but it's okay
because I need to click this analytics
button and then what we're doing is
we're doing a clip and at the end it
links to the full length episode
here's what's kind of cool just a little
interesting way to manage measure
effectiveness of things
this full-length episode highly
recommended by the way Neil dropped some
serious bombs
um this ties into our topic today too
the video had kind of Flatline but it
was slowly growing great and then do you
see you see the bump the bump is super
clear
you got a little rise right there in
results uh and all of a sudden what
happened we'll look over on the right
side
it says end screens are 34 of the
traffic
so
this video
is
288 days old
but clips from this video
uploaded on the same channel
nice valuable clip good title good
thumbnail with the end card
are
two two I believe have been published
and that's leading to two views an hour
164 views now I know it's split up
suggested still going browse but what it
what is interesting too is man if you
can provide Fresh Life to to old videos
a rising tide lifts All Ships so there's
the direct I think correlated end screen
traffic but then as people are like man
this video is fire and if watch time and
other uh metrics prove to be positive
then you could also get
clearly there's probably multiple
reasons but likewise suggested videos
and browse features are also doing well
so anyways just kind of a cool thing
measuring what matters and thinking
about the success or or the quality of
the clips you cut out I think sometimes
less is more that's where we're laning
these days I'm not actually even in love
with our Clips let me know if you have
any feedback I think that some of our
Clips like
we're just measuring but that was a cool
feedback loop of oh well that's legit
each of those clips got about 2 100
views but the original video is now to
the Moon a little bit slowly to the moon
it's gonna be a long journey but it's on
its way
all right wow
um smash like if you're enjoying some of
these tactics
TBR creators I appreciate you
um we gotta land the plane but we'll
land it at a fresh two-hour coffee with
Channel today so a couple more questions
coming your way
Lindsay uh what do you know about
invalid traffic claims on YouTube do you
know any if YouTube is using AI to
detect this my channel was affected
recently Lindsay I gotta dig more into
this I've gotten a lot of messages a lot
of tweets
and uh no excuses I know it is my
responsibility to you to have good
answers but I'm not going to make
anything up
um and uh between
hiring a bunch of people actually we're
hiring some new people
um surviving parenting and all of the
above I I just have it's been on my
radar I just haven't dug into it yet so
I don't have a good answer for you
architectural sheep matter metal
how badly do you have to be to go back
ballsy
how ballsy do you have to be to go back
and change thumbs and titles on really
high performing videos
not that ballsy I don't think because
you can always you're only changing one
thing
so change the thumbnail and be like
shoot the the click-through rate dropped
change it back
um I guess I can see what your fear
would be is like
I didn't recover I sent it into a
nosedive and I can't get it back and
like you're like oh I lost my old video
I guess I guess there's some risk and so
you do need to have a little bit some
kahunas to step out and try that but you
can always change it back and you want
to be on top of this now there are some
different tools
for that as well and um
and uh
I think
let me recommend a resource we'll link
it up
um
Nolan
molt
made a video I changed my thumbnail on
YouTube and my video exploded and so
so uh
check this out
and
thumbnailtest.com
we could we could share a link to this
as well now this is only for I would say
it's only for you know Pro Pros meaning
it's it's just kind of it's not super
expensive but just when I think about
all the tools I would recommend I would
recommend like vid IQ be like a staple
part I'd recommend everybody has vid IQ
free because that's not going to cost
you very much you know I'd recommend
everybody has like certain that like I
think budgeting for your tools
but if you get to a level
where call it hundreds thousands are
coming in a month then
15 another 15 a month here fifty a
hundred dollars you know like these all
these tools are actually super relevant
I think the mistake because I could see
some people like is this worth it is
that worth it that's also kind of the
wrong question is it worth it for you
because
the best Pros have the best equipment
you think that Tiger Woods is cheaping
out on
the gear for golf
of course not
um but not everybody is getting endless
free gear and sponsorships and clubs and
whatever because you're Tigers so it's
not like whether that's little details
from your shoes to your clubs to I don't
know anything about golf so like forgive
me they're like he said it wrong from
your putter to your driver
but the pro you two you're watching this
and and so anyways I mean thumbnail test
vid IQ uh you start getting some money
coming in let me say it another way
reinvest
in your in your business
when you start monetizing on YouTube
um scared money don't make money and too
many people get weird and they like
hesitate like
I want the best tools if I can get five
percent Improvement here 10 Improvement
here
and so I'll show you a link to you could
check this out thumbnail test now what I
taught today is
um you you don't need software to do the
strategy it's just gonna be a lot more
manual and intensive
to do it
uh
manually whereas thumbnail tests
will just report back to you and there's
all other competitor products and stuff
but the cool thing about that one is it
is
dedicated to this topic
um
okay
last question Scott
if you're in a small Niche I'm in card
gaming do you recommend making Evergreen
content that is beyond your Niche like
gaming in general to grow beyond your
Niche on occasion I I don't Scott unless
of course again you're going to get the
right subscribers because we don't want
growth for growth sake we want the right
subscribers we need the discipline
and the patience
and the long-term Vision to say
I want to attract people who have the
potential to continue to click on my
videos to continue to enjoy my videos
not just to get a subscriber to boost my
vanity metrics but
so that I can actually build a community
and build a channel
that's that's focused that doesn't
that leverages the YouTube algorithm and
doesn't fight against the YouTube
algorithm
I think one of the questions to ask
is is my original niche
big enough
to support my macro vision
almost any Niche on YouTube could
support a hobby creator
and I believe it could build into
30 40 50 60 70 000 80 000 a year
but
can every Niche be a eight figure Empire
not maybe not so it's like the kind of
thinking about this is a in in a
business school we would talk about
the total addressable market now I don't
know what you mean by card gaming
because card gaming is gigantic
so I wouldn't even call it a small Niche
unless I mean are we talking about magic
the Gathering are we talking about
Pokemon are we talking about
war with a traditional deck of cards are
we talking about are we trying to hit
all of those a lot of those things can
be very big
so we have this um we have a program
called Niche Finder I think there might
be
um I think we have something really cool
I know like our main program is usually
the best uh maybe we don't I don't know
if we have a direct link to Niche Finder
Steph Drea we could throw that in the
description too just Scott something to
check out or anybody
um I don't know if we have a special on
that right now it's a one-off it's
probably my that's I mean video ranking
Academy is my favorite thing I've
created it's our main course and usually
Niche Finder comes bundled with it I'm
doing a class and I forgot to even talk
about that I guess I I'm I am doing a
live class tonight and people know that
you know during that during classes we
we have different types of bonuses and
things that we give out but
um depending on when you join video
ranking Academy but all that to say is
back to this idea of Niche getting your
Niche right your topic right getting
your positioning right is such a big
deal
um but you could be wrong on either side
you could actually be being too negative
and say your Niche is small you also
could be misunderstanding your Niche and
actually be a lot bigger than you think
um and therefore getting Fierce Clarity
and developing a strong strategy is our
ultimate goal
because and determining if though that
you are absolutely right it's a small
niche
I don't know I'm kind of capped out on
you know I'm not sure I'm not sure it's
going to map well then where can we
pivot from here what would be something
that still aligned with your passion or
how could you maybe broaden
the channel
while still staying on brand so that
your reverse engineering back
from
um
three years from now five years from now
what's your vision where do you want
this thing to go what is it you
ultimately
um are after so appreciate you Scott
well coffee with candle look at us oh
man we
we're at two hours no we're only at one
hour and 56 minutes because I started
late so a couple things I want you to
know number one I appreciate you number
two sincerely I actually really want you
know from the bottom of my heart for the
140 of us on here live and if you're
hashtag replay fam and you're still here
salute like I mean let's just
cheers to you and I mean it because I am
humbled and grateful I know I wouldn't
get to do what I'm able to do if it
wasn't for you like if nobody watched
our videos nobody watched our content
um the nature of the crater economy is
creators are nothing without their
community and so
it means the world if you're just
stopping by for one video if you're a
think media podcast listener if you're a
part of our community I want to say
thank you on behalf of the think media
team on behalf of My Wife and Kids we
truly are humbled and grateful and want
to send you massive love and respect
um especially I know your time could be
spent a lot of different places and so
the fact that you'd hang out and spend
some of your time with me today
secondly if you got value out of today
smash like that does it is helpful and
uh lets me know that you're getting
value uh thirdly there's a lot of cool
resources we talked about in the
description
um
that are there now we talked about vid
IQ
phenomenal tool all the AI stuff that
they're putting out
really powerful there's a couple videos
we Linked UP Nolan's video uh we learned
today about linking shorts you know back
to its original long form video or I
suppose any video it actually lets you
do it to any video which is kind of a
fascinating hack of just maybe taking a
viral short I'm processing in real time
Steph Draya we should talk about this
content team you know
why not take your most viewed short
and connect it to something
um it actually that idea popped into my
head and I'm just remembering it now two
weeks ago
I did the silver play button short
because I got like this so I completely
stopped uploading on a channel for three
years and I still got a silver play
button it's kind of blown up
I was like it was a it wasn't actually a
part of a bigger video but I'm like we
should link it to some video like what
video should we link it to at least just
to test and we'll always be here to
report back to you but with that the
last thing is today at four
in just a couple hours
um I am going live Drea what's the link
um
what is the length that we share I know
it could be like two master class or
like free YouTube class or whatever I'm
gonna be talking specifically about how
I turned 130 dollars into over nineteen
thousand dollars with one video it
sounds hypey it sounds like some sketchy
Guru online and I am absolutely aware
that different things that are put out
there that I could fall into that world
but I'm deeply passionate that if you
look under the surface you say you see
that our biggest value is integrity
transparency authenticity and backing
real case studies up with real data and
showing you the real granular things
we've been able to achieve so you can do
the same and so it's a very powerful
class
um I'm gonna break down that whole story
and how you can apply it and actually on
September 19th I'm teaching it live
um it's more important now than
um well getting ready for fourth quarter
holiday shopping all that kind of stuff
is uh a very strategic time to be
watching this class
um again that's going to be free and I'm
sure Dre is hitting slack up and whatnot
looking for whatever link so we could
share that with you
um and I'll let you know about what that
is in a second but I'm super excited
about that and uh
we got green tea out here
uh Ziad sipping green tea appreciate you
Liam
I joined late so I have to catch the
replay the beginning of today's episode
is pretty fire I felt like I could have
communicated it a little bit better uh
hashtag VRA Elite yeah good to see you
busy with dogs I love it and uh yeah
we'll get you the link here in just a
second
um
that will
you know as you hear us maybe talk about
our process a little bit too that could
be one of those things uh future wise
Steph Andrea that as we look at an
episode today like on coffee with
Channel and and the marketing calendar
that's coming out that could just be
kind of a part of our show notes we have
you're seeing behind the scenes as I'm
kind of processing some of these things
uh but
we have um
a lot I mean a lot happening at think
media and so it's kind of exciting like
a lot of different moving parts and so
we're learning constantly trying to
build the systems of like I'm live at
this time at this place with this link
and all of that kind of stuff
um and so uh she's looking it up and
we'll get it added to the description as
well
um and I wonder oh I know I know where I
I can find it
I bet Tyler
posted it
on our community tab
and
if we roll over here I think because he
pulled this picture of me from Miami
what do you know about that right there
what do you know about
that's that's that's my mood right now I
want to be in this situation I'm in the
Pacific Northwest it's not warm outside
wishing I was back in Miami
um and uh free tubeclass.com
is the
uh is the link and so Drea will get that
in the description and I think I can
post it here in the live chat so that I
will be alive I'll be doing more q a and
I'm gonna be there
in um
literally three hours maybe I'm gonna
try to take a nap but I'm all
caffeinated so that's probably not gonna
work
try to reset my energy
maybe I'm gonna go on a walk at the
beach in Miami
just a six hour flight away
all right I just dropped free
tubeclass.com
and
um as we land the plane do you think the
senior co-living Niche is too small
um I I would point you to
I don't know if you're part of our Niche
Finder program already
um
but I I would say like
yeah that makes me ask a lot of
questions is it even a niche what's the
promise people how to do it who's
searching who's the target audience what
are the next 100 video ideas for that
why would someone keep coming back and
watching what I would say is
like I've got a I've got a um a friend
who has like a profitable like search
based blog with information
for like senior living I think it was
called housing for seniors.com or
something and not only was it a great
service I was helping a lot of people
but it was an extremely lucrative
business but it wasn't a YouTube channel
in the sense of like being a YouTube
Creator and having like an ongoing
channel that like seniors to subscribe
to are you also thinking about like
who's the audience people who are maybe
trying to find housing for a senior how
to thrive in co-living so he's got a lot
of questions to refine and those would
be the kind of questions that we really
walk you through in our Niche Niche
Finder program if that sounds
interesting to you if not just the tips
I gave you there I think could be super
relevant
um for identifying that and no matter
what you end up deciding I would say
that um yeah we'll get the show notes
and the resources come back to this
episode and and you can research that uh
Niche Finder program
um or just check out the full macro
video ranking Academy where we cover
that and so much more coffee with candle
it's like my name is Sean Cannell rhymes
with YouTube channel I will be back I
think in two weeks for another episode
just like this so definitely subscribe
turn on notifications and I will see you
on the fake media podcast I hope because
that happens twice a week so I'll see
you on the think media podcast peace